バンキ
ラジオそれじゃあ私とを返す
ぞのび
点もうのび太さんのお
バカ出す100
点まあ出すさん本当に頭がいいのねこれ
くらい大したことない
よだけでる
票しね僕は最近の政治経済についてはどう
思ううん私が総理大臣になったら消費前話
下げるかな最近マイクラでエンダー
ドラゴンに1200回も負けたんだよねえ
負けすぎじゃないそれでさもししかちゃん
が候補したら僕投票するよ本当
嬉しいまたねじゃ
ね疲れたであのバカのびにそこまで気を
使うんだいだって友達じゃない俺は友達だ
なんて思ってないけどね会話するだけで
バカが映りそうだもうそんなこと言わない
の行き
ましょあの偽善者片男絶対許さ
ねえのび太君どうしたのそんな興奮して人
ののレベルを下げて脳細胞を破壊して頭を
悪くする秘密道具をくれそんな道具もない
よはそう
だタイムマシン借りるわドラえもん
ちょっと待ってのび太く出き過ぎの野郎今
に似てろ
よあれが子供の出きすぎかおい小僧ゲーム
やるから勉強やめてこれで遊べよえいいの
ああいいよそのわりもう今日はしちゃだめ
だぞ分かっ
たよし
よしそうだよし行け行け行け行け行け行け
そこだよしよしよし次これべ
遊あのまんまゲームしてたら数年後には
とんでもない馬鹿になってるはず
だそれじゃあ私と返す
ぞ
伸びレテ
[音楽]
できなすぎマイナ1220
[拍手]
点なすぎ俺が勉強教えてやろかびさんだっ
て人を馬鹿にできる点数じゃないでしょす
さん私が勉強教えてあげるわ
ありがとましょう
ねどうして
えいこのポンコが目障りなんだよそうだ
そうだジャイアンの言う通りだ
イイいじめられてる出を見たら静かの
気持ちも覚めるはずおいなんとか言ってみ
な
え
ええ遡ること5年前よ
で筋トレをしていた敵はとんでもない
マチョになっていた
や俺馬鹿だからさ加減ても分からないんだ
よ
ね
やめろ敵なすさん強くてかっこ
いい行こうよしかちゃん勉強教えてよちら
ん
よちくし脳筋バカ真面目
がおびたななんだじゃやん次のリサイタル
のチケットだ売るの
手こんなにたくさん無理だろできるよな
できますじゃイ様さすが心のとよブイブイ
ブイブイブイブイ
ブイあのポンチデブゴリラ
がスを頼むイサトのチケット買ってくれ
その日はママと海外旅行に行から無理だよ
バイ
バイあの海外かれマコにやろう
がしかちゃんき頼むしかちゃんイタルの
チケットもらってごめんなさい今日私お
風呂に入る予定があるから無理なのこの女
いつも風呂入ってるけど風呂に住んでるの
か
どうしようどう
しようもうやるしかないなイイブイイイ
イイ人が見当たらねえけどチケットは売れ
たんだろう
なこんなチケット売れるわけねえだろ
俺は
つまりされに来たってことか
うわ起されるのはお前の方だじん
や俺様を舐めるな
よ伸び
たこのまま霊の場所におきてでぶっ飛ばす
とこれはじ
ガ
うわ
うわーもうおしまいだのび
た
たけし見番もしないで何遊んでんだいか
かちゃぼえ
[音楽]
けおおいおいとりあえず隠れねえとここ
しかねえ
おえあのバカ息子どこ行ったん
[拍手]
[音楽]
だ
ッキあなたが落としたのはこの綺麗な
ジャイアンですかいいえもっと汚くて
ゴリラみたいなやつです正直のご褒美に
綺麗なジャイアンをあげ
ましょうのび太君よろしくね計画通り
ほらジャイアン俺の宿題やっとけもちろん
だよ心のとよあ
あジャイアン金かせもちろんだ
よ心の友よ
あてかあの豚ゴリラまだ海にいるのかな
おいジャイアンちょっと泉行こう
ぜほら行け行けおせえ
よさすがにもう死んでる
かアクションうわあ
あなたが落としたのはこの綺麗なのび太
ですかいいえもっと目つきの悪いサイコ
パスののび太君です正直のご褒美に綺麗な
のび太をあげ
ましょうジャイアン君よろしくねああ
のび太くこちらこそ
[音楽]
[笑い]
おいのびたわざわざ俺のこと助けに来て
くれたのかえいや心のと
よブイボイボイボイボイブイえええ覚え
覚え覚え覚えおいそういえば今日新作
ゲームの販売らしいなあれ6000円も
せるんでしょ高くて買えないよじゃった
じゃーんこれ新作ゲーム
すげえママに買ってもらったんだ僕ちゃん
の骨かけはお金持ちだからねなあ俺の分も
ママにたるんで買ってくれよへえそれは
ちょっと俺たち友達だもんなうわ分かった
よママに頼んでみるよ僕のも買ってよ
のび太は友達だけど下の方の友達だから
だめ
ブブブブイブイブイブイブイ
ブイママどうしたざ今日買ってくれた
ゲームもう1個欲しいんだけど最近ゲーム
買いすぎだからダメさす
うなんでお前持ってくなかったんだご
ごめんじいや加減にしろ
お前
[拍手]
うえスネオゲームは買ってもらえたのか
それが買ってもられてなくてまたジャイア
に殴られるよそれならいい話がある
よドラえもん霊の物出してくれよでもあれ
を使うのはリスクがお前にもスネオの金で
ドラ焼き買ってやるからよ
デビルズ
カードこのカードを1回振れば
30000円手に入るその代わり1回に
つき1mに身長が縮むんだでもこれだけ
じゃ僕ちは小さくなって戻れなくなっ
ちゃうよそこでビッグライトだビッグ
ライト小さくなったらビッグライトで
大きくすればいいこれで無限に金が
稼げるのび太お前悪は天才的になくな稼い
だ半額は毎週支払う約束だぞもちろんだ
よ
ええジャイアン約束のゲームだよ
ありがとう心のとよついでに元気もお前は
やっぱり親友だなえええ
[笑い]
よ今週の支払いがまだだぞのび太のくせに
生きだぞこのライトさあればボシ1人でも
稼げるもん
ねおい待てバイ
バイあのボンボン釣りメル絶対許さ
ねえここにビッグライトを設置して準備
完了あれどうしよう電池が消えちゃっ
たおいのびたのび
たのび太頼むから助けてくれあれ1人で
どうにかなるんじゃなかったのた頼む
[音楽]
よたもう十分だってやめろ嫌なこった
あ
あ生き
たこれで本当の骨かスオになれたね
[音楽]
ああドラえもん申しボックス貸してよ
何をする気俺がこの世界の王になって
みんなを奴隷にするんだのびとドラえもん
の出会いは数年前に
遡る綺麗なたんぽぽだ
[音楽]
なえええええ何するんだよのび太が話す
なんて名前きたぞジャイアンの言う通りだ
えええええ
どうしてみんな僕のことをいじめるん
だ僕が力を持てば俺がこの世界の王になれ
ば
うのび太の負のパワーは黄色だった
ドラえもんの体
をまさに染めあげ
たのび太く落ち着いて心の中
いつもいつも描いてる描いちゃだめドレの
いる自分だけの伸びていこうこのモードに
入ったのび太君は口ではどうにもできない
力ずくで黙らせないと早くよせ攻撃もきび
たく少しは目が覚めたかいああ
おかげ様でなやれやれのび太君は自分より
不幸な人を知った方がいいねだかで
まとえ
うわどこだ
ここ何か食べ物をちょうだいは食べ物
[音楽]
逃げろいつこの戦争終わるのか
なお腹空いた
よほらこれ食えよえいいのはいえはい
えおお
この子たちは俺なんかよりよっぽど不幸
だほらおいしいだろそどってんだもっと
食べろ食べろ
[音楽]
おいしいいい
なただいまのび太くイライラとんできた
みたいだ
ねこの世には僕以外にもたくさんの不幸な
人たがいる
さだからこそ俺がこの世界の王になって
みんな秒に不幸にしないといけ
ないもしも俺がこの世界の王になっ
たらちゃちゃちゃちゃチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしく最初はチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録